let's take an in-depth look at what's
going on in politics for that we're
joined by Leslie Sanchez she's a CBS
News political contributor and
Republican strategist Leslie good
morning good morning first let's talk
about Alabama where the president is
focusing all of his efforts at this
point where do things stand down there
realistically the support is working I
think you have a lot of Republicans
let's look a base Republicans versus
conservatives who are saying this is a
lot like holding their nose for
president Trump and we want the Supreme
Court justice we want you know that was
the aim we're all aiming for one thing
they want to protect the majority but I
will say that many Republicans are
conflicted outside of Alabama in terms
of what this means for the party
what this means for the future of
candidates who want to run under the
Republican ticket that's a part people
aren't really thinking about but people
were moving away especially women when
it comes to looking at what the party
fundamentally stands for short term wins
long term losses Leslie is there the
expectation that if more does win there
will be some sort of punishment when he
arrives in Congress well you know that's
really the question the efficacy the how
how palatable is it going to be for him
to really move legislation forward when
he's been removed twice for example from
the Alabama Supreme Court for not
upholding the rule of law and the
certain priorities he had to I think
realistically you can't expect different
type of behavior he's somebody that
would probably work as an independent
move his own agenda
bet definitely have sharp elbows with
his other Republican colleagues you're
not going to really know where he's
moving and it's gonna make it extremely
difficult for the president to move his
agenda forward if your argument is that
you want a majority that works together
and the president has a very thin record
of accomplishment this year if any
that's really not that the most
strategic approach to take so do you
think there are a lot of Republicans in
Washington who are who are who are
worried that that Roy Moore move become
an albatross for the party absolutely
they're wringing their hands you know
they're holding their dollars I think
that's probably the bigger question and
even though the Republican Party let's
say the positives they've had a very
high successful fundraising you're
seeing a tremendous stock market rally
you know there's a lot of positives tax
reform is finally moving through which
is what the president promised he
probably the Supreme Court pick you
promised tax reform you're seeing those
thing
he's going to be able to talk about that
but the undercurrent is really dramatic
in terms of how people see the party the
future of the party and what it
fundamentally stands Leslee you talk
about tax reform the House and Senate
have to conference their bills or the
house has to pass the Senate's bill
there are some problems we've seen with
the bill this week in terms of the fact
that it may raise taxes on corporations
and of course adds a trillion to the
deficit is it going to happen well the
two sides of the Republican Party be
able to come together ideally we think
so it's this issue of pay throughs how
they're gonna get that down but really
tossing the issue of where the tax cuts
to balance this out are gonna come from
in the future and if you kind of listen
a little bit to what speaker Ryan's
saying about looking at entitlement
programs Senator Marco Rubio talking
about that as well that's gonna be a big
challenge
Republican President signed on without
though given his position on Social
Security and Medicare I think the
president wants a win the president has
to have a win on this and they'll fix it
later but those are really the
significant issues of how does it
address entitlement reform are we going
to get into the devil in the details and
it's still a precarious issue but I
think fundamentally we're gonna get
passage all right Leslie Sanchez thanks
so much for being with us this morning
you